[Musique]
le département a souhaité mettre en
place de nombreuses actions à
destination notamment des populations
les plus fragilisées sel dans les
quartiers politique de la ville
notamment
et chez nous aussi à un public cible à
savoir les enfants de la zone est donc
l'idée c'était de monter un certain
nombre d'opérations pour pouvoir
permettre des activités sur le temps
estival des activités de proximité c'est
vraiment de vente et toutes les
richesses que propose deux départements
des civils par rapport à l'année
dernière on a augmenté le nombre de
partenaires sur ce dispositif donc on
est à 48 partenaire qu'est ce qu'ont
proposé par on propose aussi bien des
sorciers à l'accrobranche de
morainvilliers ou au nautic par grougi
vague mais aussi la visite du château
dampierre ou de breteuil on propose
également des activités au domaine de
madame elisabeth qui est ainsi
départementale on a la ferme nature et
découvertes à versailles ça ça fait
partie des nouveaux sites
on a réussi à avoir des visites au
centre de football de clairefontaine
aussi est ce qu'on a introduit cette
année en nouvelle activité c'est la
visite du patrimoine industriel donc on
propose des visites à manque la ville
des ateliers buffet crampon
on propose également des visites sur le
site d'ariane groupe aux mureaux on a
également l'entreprise bd comme qui nous
a rejoint comme partenaire
ça se déroulera les 8 et 9 juillet sous
forme d'ateliers ses destinées à la
maison de l'enfance des yvelines amante
l'idée c'est d'associer un lieu avec un
artiste pour faire une fresque en
collaboration avec des enfants donc
voilà cet événement c'est la première
fois que le test c'est un partenariat
avec le centre pompidou et on est très
content de pouvoir aussi réaliser cet
événement-là en ouverture de quartiers
d'été